all right well thank you all so much for
joining welcome to the art studio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'll be one of your
hosts for today's rn sports analytics
meetup and i'm joined by my co-host
today mitch taney if you want to say
hello to everyone as well
yeah hi everyone uh if you're joining
here for the second time uh thank you
i'm playing the role of assistant mc
today so no presentation for me but
looking forward to the presentation
later today from michelle
awesome so if you've just joined now
feel free to introduce yourselves
through the chat window and maybe put in
where you're calling from and and say
hello
but just to go through a brief agenda
for today we'll go through some
introduction introductions uh
presentation by michelle
and then just some open q a and and
networking
and i just wanted to note that this
recording will be shared
and will be posted up to youtube
so
of course feel free to jump in and ask
questions live too but we'll also have a
slido link if you want to ask anything
anonymously or if you don't want to be
as part of the the recording
but for anyone who's just joining this
group for the first time this is a
friendly and open meetup environment
really for teams to just share the work
that you're doing within your
organizations or teach lessons learn
network with each other
but really just allow us all to learn
from each other
so thank you all so much for making this
a welcoming community
if you do ever have suggestions or
general feedback please let me know i'll
share an anonymous google form in the
chat later as well but you can always
reach out to me on linkedin or meetup
or just email me directly too
so as i mentioned i'll share that slido
link in just a second here for any
questions that you have during the talk
but with that i would love to introduce
our speaker
michelle brando
michelle is a data analyst at fanduel
and will be presenting on an
introduction to github actions
and so with that i will stop my share
michelle and turn it over to you
yeah thank you so much for having me um
so let me share
my
screen
okay everybody everyone can see it can
you see it yep it looks perfect
um so
uh today i'm going to talk about the kit
of actions um it's something that i
started working probably a month ago uh
because
uh a project that i was working aside um
and then uh so
the slogan this is the slogan uh for
github actions automate your workflow
from idea to a production
and that's pretty much uh what it
does uh automates your uh project and
uh
i was uh i've been working with the
daily coach and
i uh i'm working on creating a shiny app
uh for
uh that code so it can use for up to
help with the scouring
and um
when i was working on the project i
i need to find a way to
um to able to scrape the data
from the
g-league website um
in automatic automatic way so i don't
have to go every day and kind of do the
scraping because
uh you know pre-league plays almost
every day
and then coaches
once the game is over they quickly go
into the next one so i want to make sure
the data is updated as soon as possible
so i found the git of actions it was was
a good way uh to do it
so
i'm kind of i'm just giving a very brief
introduction of what git actions um is
and uh how to start it
um
so
it's a tool from github of course uh
they can be used in a lot of different
things uh you can use it as a test for
example if you have a package
uh if you build a package and you did
some small changes anyone you want to
test that out if you didn't break
anything you can use uh git
actions um
to uh um
to make sure you
the package looks good
um
it can deploy uh your projects with you
get github actions
um so it depends what's your goal you
can do you can do a live a lot of
different things
um
most of the github i actually i mean
most of people use github access for uh
continuous integration uh that's what is
most used for
um
you can use in a lot of different things
uh uh you can use
r python uh all
different language um
but to them of course i'm gonna talk
about uh
in r
um so
before anything that's where you start
um so you have to create a a
folder um workflow
so
uh you gotta make sure that it's exactly
uh
the
this way so you got a dockytab uh slash
workflows and then you have to create
the the work uh the github action you
gotta create a email file
and this here that's what it looks will
look like i'll explain a little bit more
as we're going
um but
definitely you got to make sure that it
is exactly you spell it exactly
like this otherwise it won't work
um so
uh the github for the most part is uh
six uh five steps and um
depending how complex it is uh you can
have uh
more jobs so we'll have a little more
steps but the first one is the events
and what is the event the event
is what what is triggers your workflow
and these two that i have here are the
most common ones i'll say but you can
customize as as much as you as you want
uh git of um does a great job with the
documentation and tells you and give you
a lot of examples
so the first
um uh
trigger that you can
do is by
push or the pull request
um so
once you push
the it triggers the workflow and will
run um the
your workflow
or your github access
another way to do it is uh
creating a crown and if you're not
familiar with the crown is
um is a way you can just timing um your
workflow and this this this part is
actually what made me to use uh gita
actually so i wanna
um
i wanna run the script or uh script the
data every er every day in the morning
so the coach who wants to go there uh
wants to go to that to the shiny app
as uh updated data and with this current
schedule if you're not uh familiar with
the syntax
so the first one here is for the minutes
the second one here is for uh it's gonna
tell you the hours the third day the
month
the next one is
uh the month and then
the last one is the um
days of the week if
you put the stars means that you'll run
you'll run this case every day of the
month it will run every day
uh every month and it will run every
every day of the week
30 here because in a minute that means
it's gonna run
uh on them on a minute uh 30 and then
here the hours that means it's going to
run in this case
uh at 5 a.m and 5 p.m so
if you if you use this um
trigger
your workflow will run every single day
at 5 30 a.m and then
5
30 p.m
and this is what i was kind of looking
for it so i don't have to come and run
uh the script every single time every
single day
so
the jobs um
so in that the jobs uh is is what you
gotta um create
to kind of is you're gonna tell the kit
of what you wanna uh do
so
it can either be you know uh run a
script or run a test or uh labels and
then
uh each job runs
as a runner
and
after
and then
its job also
as steps and actions
and um
uh you have you need to uh give an id to
the job
and
then i'll explain a little bit why
and then uh
usually you can run multiple jobs um
depending what you want uh and also also
you know within the limit of github uh
github access the guitar actions is free
but uh he has a certain limit the jobs
you can run um
for the most part jobs are
independent meaning that they run in the
um
parallel
but you can have a
adoption where they depend on each other
and if you look here
in this example here
job job you you'll run job number one
and then you have jump job number two
but
for the job number two to run java
number one is to run successful so given
a practical example
for uh actually in my case so i'm trying
to scrape
data from the
g-league website so that's my job number
one and then the job number two would be
deploying the shiny app for example so
to deploy the to the deploy the shiny
app
um i i've i i need to have the data
scraped successfully first
and then job three here in this
situation is kind of the same way so job
one and jump two got a brand uh
successful so with no errors for them
for job number three to run
so
what are the runners so the runners
are uh
type of machines where your uh job um is
run on so
github uh does a good job at hosting a
virtual environments
and it pretty much covers all the
machines so we have macs linux and
windows
and but you can also do your own uh
or create your own runner
um
and then of course i mean it depends
what you want so for example if you
wanna um
check your uh package uh that's gonna
influence what kind of um
run as you do you need
um
steps are also within the jobs
um so you with the steps you can run
commands runs the
tasks or running actions
um
again
those are the limit as long you you stay
with the user limits and i'm going to
show you next a little bit of what i all
these steps with an example and then
actions um
you can install software environment or
setup authentication um
or complete other type of things so
let's let me show you let me stop
sharing and show you
uh an example
i have here
all right
so this is an example that i ran uh this
morning so i have here the heart
r file with the scrape from
the nba so this one i wanna
here
let me show this part so this is the
data that i want to scrape
uh these are all the
um
three leak uh players from last year
regular season i want to look at
the shooting percentage uh
for each area
so
so this is the r script that i that the
code that i uh
ran to get
to scrape there
and then kind of show you here so
i already have a
the the
folder with the workflow and
this is the
email file
so
kind of tell you uh the steps that i
went through here so here's the name
just the name of the your um
action and then here is the event part
so i'm saying here um
[Music]
trigger the the action when i push
uh to the main branch
and then here is the job
also you got to give a name to the job
because if you want to uh have jobs
depending on each other you've got
fight them
um
and um so this is the runner uh that i
met i put max
you could put in this case uh either one
honestly um
because this is run on github so it
doesn't really matter uh because it's
just scraping
and then
uh this part here
you always gonna need this if you use r
this action here uh is for
um github check your repository and then
this action here is telling is telling
you the github to install r so this is
gonna make sure
it's gonna check your
repository and then also here
that uh this one that you make sure that
you have are installed
uh the next step is make sure that you
have the package that you need uh
installed as well so
you're gonna put uh install the name
install package i mean you could give it
any name you want and then run and then
you're gonna install all the packages
you need for me
because it's very simple you know i need
to set a package this is probably the
easiest way
but you you could
um
create a different outside file where
you put all the packages you need then
you just run it
and then so
as right now i have
i have the trigger um i have the are
installed and i have i told i told pitov
where to look at it
um for my repository what i want to run
so and next part is uh to run the
scripts so here
i'm going to put name my scr i call in
scrap scrape and then run so i'm saying
i'm going to put r script and then
that's the name of the r script that i
want to run so if you're going to go
look here back
uh that's the
and same name
so
um
in the
so in the in the
uh
script at the end here i tell them to
to write as the csv file
and send it as you said here send it to
the data folder
so now let me go back here so to the
to the github
so
i told i told you to run there and this
part here
is just telling me you just tell you to
you know add the the default the file to
the data folder
um
and then this is also this is just
default by github github creates a token
for you and also creates a
and then it calls actions so you need to
tap this at the end every time
um so
i ran this and if you want to look at it
so i ran this in the morning so
if you go here actions
um
so this we're running uh this morning
and if you if you see the check sign
that means everything went through and
and not in the avenue
if you see a problem here
you'll have like a red cross
so if you click it here and you want to
look at
your uh
uh action here
so here it setups the job
runs and checks your representatory
here would um
make sure r is installed
and then the next one you want to
install the package so you can see all
uh the package that
were installed
and then scrape which is the name of my
um
my art file
and everything went through with no
problem
and um
the like in the last one it's just
complete the job so
the way for me to check it i
came here uh tests
so i will code data and then
i have the file here
uh with all the data scripts
um
so but uh if you click any actions here
and then you create new workflow
um you can either so this is our package
so uh github kind of uh recommend you
um
uh a github um a workflow here this one
is for to check uh with um
our pack our package if you want to look
uh
what i'm
said in the beginning so if you want uh
double check if you're at you if the
changes you made to your package uh
didn't break anything you can use this
as um
as a workflow to kind of uh check that
but you can also also create your own uh
setup
workflow and um so
it gives you an um an example another
thing here
uh you have the marketplace where it can
give you um
different of um
actions that you can use so like if i
want to do shiny
shiny apps i click it here
and then let me actually full
and then it'll tell you here the code to
use for the shiny app
so this one will be another step or you
create you could create a new a
different job
and to deploy a shiny app
so
that's what i have for today
let me know if you have any questions
thank you so much michelle i i see a few
questions are coming in on the slido
right now
um and one that i was curious about as
well is
like thinking about this information
that you're pulling in at a high level
what information are the coaches then
accessing in the shiny app
um
a lot of um
is you know four factors um
looking at uh shooting percentage uh
by um
by uh location
um location um
[Music]
efficiency
team efficiency player efficiency look
at
lineups um
those are the type of things they they
look at they are looking for
um
with with the coach and i'm working on
it with the
um it's it's more kind of like put in
the way where uh that coach can you know
um just go right away understand what
what kind of things uh uh that coach
needs to look at it
and
and is there for uh to kind of support
the scouting force
thank you
i see richard asked
a question about what are the most
important packages that you use
and i think this would be helpful to ask
the whole audience as well if people
want to share in the chat too
for this specific project or just in
general
i think it might be in general but
richard feel free to jump in as well
um
i mean it depends what you want uh of
course uh i mean we know tight reverse
is a well-known package everybody uses
is very handy
it depends if you want to scrape
if you want to um
do
modeling um
[Music]
so
tidy models for example
i mean i
think it depends what is your goal and
what you want to accomplish
with your project and
yeah richard do you want to did you want
to jump in there or add any context to
that question
um and it also may be helpful for the
audience too to share a few helpful
packages as well and maybe we could
compile a list of
helpful packages for sports analytics
another question anonymous question is
do you have some resource
recommendations for going more in depth
on this topic
uh i mean you just use github
documentation uh i think they is very
good um
probably that'll be the first
step or the
where to go
that's what i i
i use for the most part honestly
thank you
and again if anybody wants to ask
questions live feel free to as well
otherwise i'll go through some of the
slido questions
um one of the anonymous ones
was is there a python equivalent of your
code
uh
um
this crampy part or actually the the
actions
the
so
with gita but you can use python as well
yeah
if that's the question uh the scraping
of i mean i believe so i'm not familiar
with it
but i think yeah for sure that is that
is a similar package where you can
scrape from the ipa api
awesome thank you
um and then uh stefan i see that you
just asked a few questions in the zoom
chat too and one being either memory
limits subject to the action
um and feel free to to jump in as well
stephan
hi so
um greetings from switzerland
i
have exactly this question because um
it seems it is a serverless
service
github action is about it is it true
so that
if you run your your scraping um
routines
then
there must be a virtual machine where
it's running on or at least there must
be a hardware uh where it is performed i
suppose yes gita is like a virtual
machine that's what the runners i uh
are for so you can simply use what
virtual machine you want but you can use
you can use
your own or customize your own as well
the question i have is if i would scrape
a little bit more of data that
as i've seen it now
and i have maybe
in the memory
four gigs of data
is it possible or not
for instance i have tasks running in r
which have 5.6 gigs
i'm not 100
sure
i would say yes um
but i could be wrong i mean yes my my
example is is very little so i had no no
issue i haven't tried with the
with the
uh bigger data
member
uh someone dropped a link in the chat
for the pricing for github actions and
there are storage limitations
associated with that so
yeah make sure you take a look at that
reference
gta action is free if is a public
repository
so if he's public you it
should be free of course with
limitations but
those limitations are are pretty big
thanks a lot
thank you i think david asked a question
you said great method to automate data
refreshes
could you discuss other approaches to
automating data refreshes
and you said for example our studio
server
i don't know if that's a question that
you want to answer michelle or i could
ask mitch as well
yeah maybe i'm uh mitch probably will be
a better resource for this one
so on the
in terms of can you ask the question
once again rachel i just want to make
sure i understand what the context was
there yeah and david feel free to jump
in too but i see it um the question was
this is great method to automate data
refreshes
could we discuss a few other approaches
to automating data refresh
as well
yeah i'll i'll approach that a little
bit here from the
from the professional product side of
things so on our professional products
we have
those are server based products as well
and
if you're not familiar rstudio connect
is essentially a deployment
uh host for all of your data science
products so in this particular example
one method of doing that would be to
take your script that script that
michelle had written and drop that in as
an r markdown document you can then
actually publish that our markdown
document to our studio connect and
there's a scheduling feature on our
studio connect that would allow you to
have that data refresh
at different
different time iterations
so yes there are other ways to
uh refresh data and again that's kind of
more on the professional side of uh
with our studio products but connect
would allow you to do that
and uh david feel free to jump in if you
have any
follow-up question there too
i'm trying my best to have us all like
pretend we're in a real room right here
but i know it's very hard
virtually
um
another question is it looks like for
the shiny example that
you supplied github with the environment
variables for the shiny credentials
and someone just wanted to know how do
you actually do that uh
you you have there in
once you log in on your chinese
website
so if if once you you uh
is the shiny
uh shiny app
okay so that's on shiny apps
yeah and then you click on your app and
then uh it has a settings there where it
shows you the details and one of those
are those
credentials
thank you
um and again if that doesn't answer the
question feel free to clarify on
on slido or in the zoom chat too
um
pawnee or apologies if i pronounce your
name incorrectly i saw you asked what's
a good way to learn github actions for
beginners
uh honestly just doing i know start a
little and then build from there uh
that's kinda
how i started
um
i mean that's that's always the best way
michelle if i can jump in here with a
related question can you talk a little
bit more about your motivation for doing
this and
uh i think that's one thing and i know
you said you tried to
you know you wanted to automate this
script but can you talk a little bit
more about resources that you
potentially used to because i think
that's probably one question that
others on this call may be considering
is i have this i may have a related
problem and this is a great resource
i'm sure you used others as you were
putting this together so can you talk
maybe just a little bit about uh some
other resources that you may have used
to just put some of these pieces in
place because more often than not i
think it's a when you're trying to solve
a problem such as this it's i'm taking a
little bit from this section this
resource i'm thinking a little bit from
this section to kind of fit what i need
done
yeah honestly i i mean i've been um
i heard about github actions for a while
and uh um i kind of started deciding to
take a look um when i had the problem uh
i mean i i
i
i don't know much about the connect i
want but i you know you have package
where you could deploy uh
or refresh yours r script uh in your
machine
but for me i think the most important
part it was the optimization part where
i didn't need to be on my computer to to
kind of uh run the the script and uh
github
actions kind of did
add all of that so
um honestly i didn't i didn't
go too far from it because you kind of
add everything that i need it
um
i'll i'll be honest i haven't tried the
the the deployment part of the uh the
shiny app that's the next step for me
so maybe um you know with the shiny
because it's a little more complex i'll
probably need a little more i need other
resources but i think for
for the this part with scripts uh to
script the data i think i mean is is
very easy
um and uh
it does it does the job for you
sorry i
no that that's helpful um
i'm also i'm curious myself like how
that process went for you internally
like were people already using
r or did you kind of have to explain
um
like what shiny is if or thinking about
sharing that with people or what was
that process like
um
yeah well the the coaching now didn't
know much about chinese uh
she can't the coach kind of come with me
and with a promise and like listen i
i need something where i um
can make my life a little easier in
terms of uh during the season with the
scouting instead of just going
to the cheerlead website and try to find
all the stats
that coach need
and i kind of honest with my side i kind
of suggest they i can probably create
an app that looks like a website
they have all the information that you
need right right there and you don't
need to go
to 20 pages to to look for the
information
that you needed for that specific game
because even sometimes for
um you know if it's
every game is different so they might
need information for one or some
information from one game and another
type of permission for another
and then um
and instead of being 20 pages is 30
pages so
for that coach it was more i how i can
make my life easier um
during the season because he's already
crazy with the amount of games they have
with the amount of practice and all the
responsibilities they have
um
and uh you know if i
uh save an hour a day
that's that's that's huge
so
they didn't know where they could you
know what
is still not no honestly which is fine
uh
so you know as long that coach knows how
to navigate with the with the shiny app
uh is totally fine with me
we kind of talk um with each other see
the best ways to kind of
um how you display better how you um
what kind of things you want and what in
a certain order they want it um
so
i pers
oh do we lose michelle for a second
while michelle's dialing back in i think
she her internet dropped for a second
but i'm curious if other people on the
call are using
r for that purpose as well
with scouting
i'm gonna force somebody to talk to me
at some point here
rachel i can kind of chime in here yeah
a little bit i think just as
michelle gets set back up again i think
it's important
for others here on the call to if you're
just getting started and you're not sure
hey how do i how do i do something
uh
i think the way that michelle described
her process and her the kind of
motivation behind it is that
there was
you're solving a very specific problem
for another member in your organization
and it can be as simple as
just aggregate aggregating data from
different locations and
my recommendation based on my
experiences is similar what michelle has
kind of described here is that
uh try to find small victories
uh rather than trying to maybe plan
something out for hey this is going to
be a 12 month to 18 month project like
the timelines with a lot of sports
organizations are very condensed
uh because of the season because of the
volume of games or whatever the case may
be so try to focus on small victories
especially as you're getting started
just to help uh create more efficient
processes streamline workflows for other
members in your organization and often
that then leads to larger opportunities
bigger scale type projects especially as
you're getting started so i think the
way that michelle described as uh in the
motivation for her project saying hey
someone needed uh rather than going to
20 different websites we were trying to
just
create a centralized
resource for data and i think that's a
really
uh
really good approach to solving a
problem for an organization
and it looks like michelle is on so i
will turn it back over to her i already
mind her nanny's been bad no problem
michelle was just saying that just as we
were as you were trying to get back
connected again just
uh i commended you for your approach in
terms of solving a problem within your
organization
and using just data aggregation is one
step to potentially and how that may
potentially lead to future conversations
and maybe you can talk a little bit
about this in terms of
what is what's transpired since you've
put this in place has that led to
additional conversations has that led to
potential uh more interactions with your
coaching staff
well uh
it's kind of still a
building process uh the goal is to be
ready to go
before the season um
this is a side project so
i'm not directly working for the
organization honestly i'm just working
with a specific coach
um
but i mean i'm i'm hoping kind of you
know
help from from from here in terms of
what they need uh
uh with the things they look uh for and
kind of makes their life
easier um that's that's that's the goal
and then it's kind of we'll see i mean
how the scene goes and the goal is he's
kind of
for the coast to test it out and see
if it helps if it does help will help
the most with things uh we could improve
um and then and then kind of go from
there
what did that communication process look
like in like from the beginning like i
know they
the coach said oh i have this problem
that i need you to help me solve but
did they kind of have an idea of what
they wanted it to look like
or did you like draw it out or
um
it was kind of bold
so
they did have an idea i kind of suggest
a few things or show a few things out
how we could look like um given examples
example
from college
kind of
be a mix of the
um
the
the g-league website um
and uh it kind of build it you know
together in a sense sorry i made this
change can you look it up how did you
like it do you want this way do you want
that way uh
one time the coach i said told me that i
i prefer f this table up top so kind of
work together and see
what things
um you know they like better what things
they prefer
and um
and try to to please them as as much as
possible insist because they they are
the ones they're going to work with it
they are the ones they're going to use
it so the easiest for them
the more they're going to use it and
that's kind of the goal
thank you i see there's one last
question in the slido chat and then i'm
going to
double check the zoom chat too but it
says
do you also use or have you used docker
if so are there any like major usage or
feature differences you've noticed uh i
i am gonna use it i know you can use
docker with github's uh actions with the
kit of actions uh
uh i don't know much about it it's
something i've heard it uh but it is
it's definitely something that i look
forward to to kind of learn a little bit
more
definitely
thank you so much michelle and i'm
thinking just like scrolling through a
bit in the chat and i see bill you have
um
some perspective that you've just shared
there as well and wondering if you'd
want to jump in live and chat about that
yeah hi can you hear me yep i can
you know i i was just just adding to i
think there was just a question around
you know and i think
in the sports world in particular but i
think you also find this in different
organizations um you know where time is
of the essence um for for leaders
managers coaches whatever happens to be
um and i've seen this just within sports
itself
there's so much that people are doing
manually um trying to prep trying to to
look at how you know they can improve
their players um and especially right
now
data is not something that they're
trying to get their hands on they're
flooded with it
and they spend so much time trying to
corral the data and just get it into a
form that makes sense to them and that's
you know they kind of develop their own
processes to say hey this is how i'm
going to evaluate a player track how
they're doing find where their their
weak spot is what to improve on and it
takes them so much time to manually get
the date the data into the shape that
they like to view it in um so just in
terms of you know if you're working with
people or trying to almost find a
gateway for them to you know take more
advantage of analytical work
i do think that anything you can do to
save people time even if it seems simple
doesn't have to involve any kind of
fancy modeling whatsoever but just being
able to save them time and get them
something that's automated and and you
know they can have something in you know
an hour versus two days that would take
them to themselves um i think that's
usually something that makes folks very
receptive to what else can you do right
let me let me tell you about this other
thing this other idea i have is there a
problem i have um and that that can
usually be a pretty good gateway into
into
partnering with them more and getting
them to open up and have you know more
asks of this kind of work
that's like a great point
thank you so much and
i'd love to have other people jump in as
well if if you have things to share um
trying our best to pretend we're all
sitting around in
like a conference room or at a meet up
something i'd like to ask the whole
audience is
are there specific resources that have
been really helpful for you or
um
in particular around sports analytics
like either for finding certain packages
or learning how to do certain tasks
hi
well for me
hey david yes you're a little quiet but
i can hear you
what is that
there you go i can hear you
please so for me um
not specifically related to um spots
but that's still product analytics to
make right and something that's been
really helpful
in projects has
has been um
the our studio projects
management's highly quality
management
ability sort of to be able to
go from project to project right
from yeah right so usually and one very
very big
um addition that has done for me is
project management right from the
beginning of the video it looks very
easy to
skip some of those things right building
a core extra time our studio
right but as the previous skills
managing through those becomes really
important
that's equally helpful in that yeah
definitely thank you
um
brian i see you asked a question just in
the zoom chat here
and a few other people are sharing a few
helpful links of
uh resources but brian asks any advice
for someone who wants to get into sports
analytics like volunteering to help a
simple project
that bill mentioned earlier or how to
network with coaches
michelle do you have any advice yes
honestly you know have something really
push out and then contact the coaches is
the best way um
you know
uh
they want if if they need help or if
they if you come up with something
they're gonna help them they're gonna
they're gonna hear you so
um you know try
um and i know it's hard sometimes
uh if you're not in the field but try to
reach out to coaches
and kind of show them hey this is what i
build
um are you interested uh i think i could
help you some some something in those
lines
um
i think that would be probably the best
way to go about it
yeah
oh i was just curious if michelle you
just reach out to them over email or or
linkedin or how do you know
this one i was i knew the coaches so i
kind of
you know i play basketball overseas um
so it kind of opens up a little bit
the doors for me uh
but uh but yeah i mean i've been reach
out to coaches before uh on
uh for those for some reason so think
kind of build your network show that you
can do things that help them and uh they
they
they
will they are willing to to kind of work
with you i mean
if you go for nba of course probably
it's a little harder because they have
all the resources but maybe if you go
for low levels like college or even
chili i mean really
um
they
they have some resources but it's not as
like nba for example so yeah definitely
professional sports or the major uh
sports side of the
is a little harder because they do have
the resources
but if you want to start in the sports
maybe try um
low levels college basketball football
um even football now they have uh the
mid-major uh the big m uh
but try and meet majors for example they
probably have those resources for
football for college football for
example um so yeah definitely have
something ready to show
and um
and contact our network as much as you
as you you can
i don't know from a channel
yeah i was gonna say michelle your
example here today about that was more
of a workflow related
uh example and it was because you'd had
that engagement with
a coach and had a conversation about
like hey we need to solve this very
specific problem what i would add to
that is for someone who may be
completely
outside of sports looking to get into
sports one thing that captures the
attention of peop of coaches personnel
people just front offices is winning
so if you can
if you have a study you have an analysis
that
says hey this increases the likelihood
of a win by x percent or
overall wins increases by
whatever the number is that's going to
capture the attention more often than
not of someone that's working for a team
working for an organization because uh
especially at the highest levels of
sport it really comes down to
one thing and that's winning and so if
you can if you have analysis that shows
that
in addition to the workflow
discussion which again i think maybe
sometimes might be a little more nuanced
uh as you're working within an
organization or in michelle's example
you have a specific connection to
someone and you've had that uh back and
forth but
winning is the ultimate objective at the
you know at the highest level so if you
have analysis that says hey this is
going to help this is going to help your
organization win uh that could be
another
entry point for some of you who are
maybe outside of sports looking to get
into sports
for sure thank you mitch
um i i did also notice the oh brian i
see you unmuted so i'm going to take
that as raising your hand
sure um
that's a that's a great point and
actually
it's a universal point
um when i worked in marketing research
and consulting we had our our
intellectual property
we sold a ton of business because we
could show that
a company's roa
was correlated with a linear regression
at us at a highly statistical level with
these benchmarks
and
uh honestly that was a piece that sold
everything just like winning so this was
you know for to your traditional
business person you increase your
shareholder roa or your roe
you're going to make people happy
they're going to listen to you
and you know we have the statistics and
and the regression that showed it um you
know each amount of dollar that they did
this or did that was an incremental gain
um and it speaks volumes you know and as
you said with sports it's about winning
so
you know for people wanting anything
find the metric that's most important
it's not the same for every industry
um
but that's what's going to get people to
listen to you
that's a great point brian
and speaking of the metrics that are
most important i see simon you asked
what are the typical asks for analytics
teams
from coaching staffs in basketball so
similar to the nfl fourth down decision
problem
uh i
do not have any experience to work with
the teams uh
so
i mean the only thing that i was asked
is just kind of build this app um
but uh you know i'm sure
uh coaches ask similar questions for
basketball so instead of another fourth
down is if you should fall at the end
of the fourth quarter when you up by one
for example
um
or a bite yeah by one uh by
up by two so
um
i think it would be the same uh
uh type of resource kind of think about
uh problems that you use or um
situations in basketball and and and
look at what would be the best strategy
um
player develop i think is a big thing
coming up too it's like how what kind of
metrics or what kind of things they can
look at it to to improve
players
um
yeah i mean uh
i don't know if uh mitch has some
important this um
i personally never work with for
organization um
i was with then i played but at that
time
or the resources were not as much we
didn't have any um
analytical team you know so our course
didn't use
but i don't know if mitch has
an input on that
i just dropped a couple links into the
chat of a few follows that i'd recommend
on twitter so the first is ben falk
ben used to work for the
trailblazers and then the 76ers i know
ben
personally i think he's one of the
smartest people i've ever met so it's a
plug for him and his work he has a
website called cleaning the glass
i highly recommend it for those of you
that are interested in just learning
more about basketball analytics he
provides just a unique perspective
on how data can be used in basketball
and then also i
added seth partnow or partnoy maybe
mispronouncing his last name but
seth has uh
has experienced both in basketball he
worked for the milwaukee bucks he's also
written for the athletic and i think
most recently he's actually working with
uh stats bomb
um so again just unique perspective
coming from a lot of different angles
talking about analytics and sport and
specifically basketball
and seth if you hear this i if i
butchered your last name i apologize
thanks mitch
um one other conversation i see
happening in the chat and i just wanted
to
dive into it if anyone wants to add
anything um i see luke you were asking
around
um
you're saying people are running this
type of data for
dfs which i learned today is daily
fantasy sports
and props as soon as prices are revealed
time is of the essence the sooner you
can organize data you find value
um luke do you want to speak to that at
all or anyone want to jump in on that
conversation
is that um
i know today your presentation michelle
is more so on
like a side project and working with
this this team
um but i'm curious is that something
that you work with today at fanduel or
or what does that work uh yeah i do work
with uh daily fantasy
um
so
uh yeah i mean you can use uh this type
of data or
kind of predict performance
to see the value of
that player's specific player for the
daily fantasy
it's definitely a way to to look at it
kind of advantage
um
you i mean for sure yeah
uh sci-fi i see you raised your hand
did you want to add anything
no there's a question and not especially
for this one this is a great session you
know i really enjoyed it and i took all
the
notes that people have put onto the uh
chat links um so hopefully i can
follow some of these and start educating
myself a bit more
um what i'm keen on is that
would you be able to see something
similar
as a
next session or in next few months
a talk especially upon
you know how to analyze um
you know
cyclist performance performance you know
like the
professional cyclist performance um
is is that something that we could look
at
definitely if we can find someone who
wants to
to speak about it um
for sure if we can uh
maybe do yes
i'm on the i'm only you know i'm keen on
that particular sports i'm also keen on
r but i've not reached to that stage
that i can do it myself
but i'm just trying to bridge that gap
basically that how can i actually start
analyzing some of the
you know beta because uh
cycling is a
heavily data-intensive um sports
nothing uh gets as competitive as you
know
cycling
and extracting data in real time and
then kind of a
making some um quick decisions based on
the real-time data
and i was just wondering if we could get
some example um using our um you know
if somebody is able to
bring that to life then that'll be
fantastic
definitely
yeah
and then another
good place that and i just wanted to
mention this before we all go is
um we did start a a channel on the r for
data science online learning community
dedicated to sports analytics um so that
could be a great place to
ask that question too and try and and
connect just connect with different
people there oh is that group available
on the
linkedin yeah i'm just going to put it
in the chat right now how you joined
thank you um so it's r for ds
dot io slash join
um and then
once you're as part of that group you
can join right away
there's a
channel that's just called sports
analytics
and so it's i'm just going to type the
channel name as well
yeah but it's also a great place for us
all to to follow up with other questions
and if we have resources or packages we
want to share i can go through this chat
and
pull the list for you as well i'm in
there too
oh cool thank you um
and then one other thing about the next
meetup too um so that you know what to
expect for the future
i just posted a placeholder invite for
wednesday november 10th
at the same time so 12 eastern time
tom bliss is going to be presenting on
the nfl big data bowl
so if anyone's interested in that would
love to have you there as well
before we go i just want to open up to
see if
there are any other last questions that
you want to ask michelle
try and wait a few more seconds here
thank you all so much for joining i put
into the chat right now if you ever have
any suggestions or general feedback on
the meetup there's a google form there
where you can include some feedback
um
would love to have you all join us
speakers in the future too so feel free
to reach out to me and meet up or
linkedin
or email me directly
but just want to say thank you so much
to michelle for speaking i really
appreciate it thank you so much for
inviting thank everyone to to show up
and the next one i saw just someone just
asked in the chat is november 10th at 12
eastern time
and i'll announce that on the meetup
site and then make a linkedin event for
it too
but thank you all for joining and have a
great rest of the day
[Music]
you